the meme of all memes of me melting down
to Nancy Joe is sent to me almost on a
daily basis on Instagram and now I
absolutely find it really funny
Nancy Joe this is Alexis Neiers come
going to let you know and I can laugh at
those parts of myself because it is kind
of comical right I mean it's sad and
there was heartbreak and there's
definitely stages of healing and now I'm
at the point where I can laugh at myself
and say okay this is completely absurd
it was honestly and like the it was one
of the greatest reality TV moments ever
that was such a great meltdown and we
really just slayed it all out there
really did
do you have it memorized Nancy Joe this
is Alexis Neiers calling to tell you
that I'm very disappointed in your
article there were many things that I
saw in here that were not true like you
saying that I wore six-inch Louboutins
to court when it was really four inch
and then my mom yells $29 and then mine
is every time you yell I had to rerecord
it it will never get old on my like
slide up red little foam that I was like
clutching onto for dear life amazing I'm
impressed would you be willing to relive
the voice
[Music]
no this is Alexis I'm calling to it you
know how disappointed I am in your story
and the way that you sued on me when I
am going through time in my life I
opened up to you so that way the world
could potentially know strong then I am
not even a young woman I am petrified
with this story oh I'm so disappointed
and I'm letting you know that I will
clear this up have a nice life goodbye
[Music]
your mom Best Supporting I mean that's
Supporting Actress right hey my eyebrows
have made such a good comeback and be
the end of that is really actually sad
I've never seen like all the way through
I haven't in a long time because I
always just see the memes of me yelling
over and over and over again but yeah I
mean the poor thing yeah she's really
heartbroken it's really hard for me
she's had she's fine I love that I use
that word it's crazy because that feels
like I'm watching somebody else yeah
like I feel like that's not me I mean
even talking to you now I'm like this
this is not like we're watching some
like hilarious meme from ten years ago
yeah I don't feel like I'm talking to
the same person at all I recorded that
voicemail so many times and the final
moment where I blew up like that was
after many takes of doing that that
recording this was back in the day where
if it didn't read your voice now
register your voice mail it would say
we're sorry but you know please rerecord
after finished press one and so I just
kept our ear according andrey recording
and that's the famous line to my mom but
every time you yeah i have to record it
because she would yell in the background
and then it wouldn't pick up the audio
on the voicemail and i would have to do
it over and over again yeah
I was like I'm just trying to get
through this scene and can you like shut
up and so I can finish like I just want
to be done I just was humiliated I mean
people didn't get to see the behind the
scenes they saw little clips of me
meeting with Nancy Joe and of course the
clips that the producers liked which is
me talking about how I wanted to be like
Angelina Jolie or whatever I was are
like a yeah it was all like the bad
parts but I had sat with Nancy for hours
and hours talking to her she was someone
that I really trusted and she promised
me you know we made a conscious choice
that we weren't gonna do any media
except for her so this was kind of gonna
be like my one shot at not that I had
many redeeming qualities back then
because I did it but I was just like
child it was 18 18 yeah just turned 18
when we started filming the show so you
know I really I trusted her and so here
comes the article and I'm so excited to
read it she had said she wasn't gonna
talk to any other members of flavoring
all of the stuff and then I read it and
then I was like oh my god not only is
this not what I expected but she's
fabricating what I'm wearing into court
and all of that and and so it was pretty
devastating you one fact wearing maybe
she chews
yeah well that made her Brown because
when I got she blocked me on Twitter
because he went and pulled the footage
and proved that I was wearing the shoes
and then she yeah that wasn't Pleasant
oh wow have a nice life goodbye it was
beautiful you did such a good job of
expressing yourself
[Music]